donald trump le président américain lui
a mis en exécution vendredi sa menace de
couper les ponts avec l oms
il avait déjà suspendu la contribution
financière accordée par sont payés à
l'agencé onusienne qu'il accuse de
complaisance envers pékin a de son côté
l'union européenne appelle washington à
changer la vie les précisions c'est avec
crânien berrada
c'était une menace persistante c'est
désormais une réalité
l'amérique de donald trump coupe
unilatéralement les ponts avec
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
à l'origine de cette rupture la
politique de l'om est ce que le
président américain juge trop
complaisante avec la chine depuis le
début de la pandémie de kovy 19e' n'a eu
de cesse d'appeler l'organisation
onusienne a davantage de fermeté nous
avons détaillé les réformes que l' oms
devait engager directement avec la chine
mais l'organisation a refusé de ce refus
a engagé des réformes
nous nous retirons immédiatement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
allons nous tourner vers d'autres
organisations publiques dans le monde
qui méritent notre aide
le monde a besoin de réponses de la
chine sur le virus
nous avons besoin de transparence avec
893 millions de dollars apportés sur la
période 2018 2019 soit environ 15% du
budget de l'om est ce les etats-unis en
sont le premier bailleur de fonds loin
devant la chine et ses 86 millions la
contribution américaine va
essentiellement en afrique et au
moyen-orient qui seront donc les
premiers impactés par le retrait des
états unis un retrait qui constitue un
sérieux revers pour la santé mondiale
juge de son côté le ministre allemand de
la santé
ils appellent l'union européenne a
alloué des fonds plus importants à l'om
s il s'agit d'un sérieux revers pour la
santé mondiale
si l'on veut que l'om espèce à l'avenir
il faut engager des réformes et l'union
européenne se doit d'avoir un rôle de
leader et de s'engager davantage
financièrement ce sera l'une des
priorités du ministère fédéral de la
santé
au cours de notre présidence européenne
la décision de donald trump survient
alors que la pandémie de co vite
neuf continue à faire des ravages aux
états unis le pays le plus touché tant
nombre de morts que 2k a franchi
mercredi la barre des cent mille décès